I have one piece of information for you.
prosecutor Ziobry
not only on this podium gave me your time
But your time is up in politics.
you can scream
you can wave your arms
you can make a fuss
but it won't do anything
You are no longer in government.
and you can take the floor one last time as minister
but you gave testimony
How you treat parliamentary standards
and constitutional standards
What have you done with this KRS?
What have you done with this most important organ?
who is to stand guard
our rights and our civil liberties
you made yourself a machine
Appointment of such judges
Those who do not support the Constitution
Do not stand by the letter of the law
They stand by the statute of the Law and Justice Party.
those days are gone